oh no oh the father had a lot to do with
it my father he's a veterinarian my
mother was a nurse and both of them you
know being in healthcare sort of prodded
me towards the sciences I thought I was
going to be in humanities either you
know end up as a novelist somewhere or
or some you know an attorney but
something in humanities and arts not in
science because to me it were it was
science was learned for me humanities
was sort of innate it was something I
thought I had naturally I did a lot of
him high school acting and you know
reciting poems writing poems you know
the first draft of my novel which has
just got published was written right
after my high school oh well I always
wanted I love literature a lot growing
up so we read all the African literature
Chinua Achebe things fall apart
everybody knows that things like that
and that you really really enjoyed it so
you know I thought to myself in it one
day I'm going to write like Gina watch a
way and right after high school I
started the first draft you know it
didn't go very far but I took that
manuscript with me and sort of talked it
away and for the next ten years it was
sort of lost in my box in my suitcase
somewhere and finally after grad school
I picked it up again dusted it really
know sort of rewrote the whole thing and
you know but they the theme remained the
same and as of this action as of
yesterday i received the author's copy
so I'm published like the name of the
book
vapor of life and it's a purely fiction
based on life in Nigeria and life in the
United States actually I think right
actually informs and makes you a better
scientist because no matter what science
you do you've got to express it
somewhere and communicate it to the
audience you know you can't just do your
signs and keep to yourself the other
part is communications you know writing
up what you've done so help you know
just grooming that skill set that I have
has made me a better scientist because I
can also communicate the signs that I do